Almost since day one, I've been telling you
that we are dealing with an actual virus that
spreads virally, but we are also dealing with
disinformation that's spreading virally and
ignorance that is spreading virally. And this
came to a head over the weekend with protests,
protests of huge groups of people crowded
together, mostly without masks, demanding
that their states be fully opened in the middle
of a viral pandemic. And they are almost exclusively
Trump supporters, not all, but mostly. Donald
Trump has actually started to be supportive
of them on Twitter and during press briefings.
We'll get to that a little bit later. And
these are quite simply actions that are going
to spread the virus and lead to more deaths.
We're now starting to see the results of Wisconsin
voting in person. And we're seeing spiked
infections in Wisconsin. It takes 10 to 14
days to see that. And we are now seeing it.
And much the same is going to happen here.
So let's take a brief sort of tour of the
country over the weekend. Note that Fox News
promoted these as rallies slash protests to
reopen the economy with a nice map rather
than as the dangerous mass gatherings that
represent a risk to public health.
And indeed, these have been chock full of
the exact type of wacky behavior that you
would expect and imagine much of it couched
under the umbrella of people are demanding
their rights and people are demanding freedom
and so on and so forth.
We are putting video up of one of the protests
in Columbus, Ohio. Of course, no surprise
filled with Tea Party Don't Tread on me flags
also during many of these rallies, including
the one in Columbus, Ohio. No shortage of
anti-Semitism. Someone in a van stopping with
a sign that says the real plague with a picture
of a stereotypical anti-Semitic cartoon and
a star of David on it. It's a nice touch that
at all of this stuff, somewhere, there's anti-Semitism
and often homophobia as well.
Images from Florida with signs like Live Free
or Die. Liberty and Freedom Now and give me
liberty or give me death. And what they're
getting right about this is that indeed this
is an issue of life and death. Another young
woman protester with a sign that says, no
masks. My body. My choice. Trump 2020. Now,
there have been both serious and satirical
versions of this sign showing up at different
ones of these protests. The irony of the entire
thing, of course, is that Trump is against
abortion. So anybody arguing about my body,
my choice when it comes to the masks, but
supporting Trump, Trump is okay, I guess,
with forcing someone to have a kid based on
his newfound anti-abortion position, which
he learned at about 68 years old, that that
was actually the right position.
But she'll be damned if she's going to put
on a surgical mask, OK, being forced into
having a kid, but no surgical mask whatsoever.
Here's a video from Texas of a large crowd
without masks. Chanting all sorts of things,
including fire foushee. And yes, if you are
watching, you will notice that at least one
person in the crowd is wearing an Alex Jones
infowars t shirt. Not a surprise. Take a look.
And then here is a video from Brookfield,
Wisconsin, where you see Trump, Pence signs,
Magga signs, the Tea Party Don't Tread on
me signs and everything that you would expect
at one of these rallies. We have video from
Encinitas, California, people with the same
Tea Party flags, Trump signs, some. They're
actually wearing masks, which is interesting.
But a lot of the people just looking sort
of confused about what they're even doing
and where they even are. Conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones also showed up at one of these
rallies.
It's too dumb to even play video of. It's
too predictable to show you video of. But
you can find it online. And then last one,
because this is just bonkers. A woman in the
Tony neighborhood of Huntington Beach, California,
standing in front of a Baskin Robbins ice
cream shop with a sign that says Give me liberty
or give me death, because, of course. Anything
short of 45 flavors is indeed slavery. So
we're in real trouble here. And I I don't
want to discount the reality that if you are
one of the 22 plus million people who has
lost their job, you are an increase in an
increasingly desperate situation.
We've got stimulus money that is being delivered.
We have unemployment insurance enhancements
for people who have lost their jobs. And this
all has been weaponized not primarily as an
economic issue, but as a political issue,
as an issue of freedom and liberty and of
the constitution and all sorts of other things
that these protesters are misunderstanding.
This is about one thing health risks and public
health and safety.
There are more good analysis which suggest
the economic impact of the closures is far
smaller than the economic impact of the virus
actually running rampant. You know how Trump
talks about, hey, if we had done nothing.
2.2 million people would have died up to 2.2
million. And there would have been potentially
hundreds of millions of people infected. That
the economic impact of that would have been
far worse than what is hopefully the temporary
economic impact of what is being done, at
least by some states here. Now, there are
a ton of southern states and others that didn't
have that many cases last week, and they're
very quickly becoming hotspots. Ohio at 12000
cases with more than a 10 percent increase
per day on two consecutive days. If that rate
of growth continues, you can have a real problem
very, very soon. Texas is growing. Florida
is growing. Virginia. So these are the states
most likely to reopen the soonest. And yet,
if this continues, these are going to very
rapidly be the states that are worse off and
their economies will suffer as a result. We
will watch. The direction things are pointing
is that we are going to essentially have waves
of overlapping opening, closing for months
and months, if not a year, without really
getting it under control. If and until we
get a working treatment, therapeutic treatment
as well as a vaccine, that's what's going
to happen if we have this patchwork of states
opening and closing very often for political
reasons. I'm going to devote some time now
to Donald Trump's fomenting of these very
dangerous protests.